The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So where we left it
last time is the access to
family planning, the access to
contraception, et cetera, did
not play such an important
role in keeping people's
families small.
It doesn't mean that it's
not a good thing to do.
It certainly helps people
time their fertility.
It makes them happier and all
other good things, but it was
not the main determinant
of family size.
And so then the next question,
obviously, is then what is the
determinant of family size?
If people are not constrained
by their lack of access to
contraception to choose the
family size that they want,
how do they decide to choose
their family size?
And there are, I think, only
two big classes of factors
that might matter.
One is social factors, so both
what the community thinks is
right, what the country thinks
is right, what your husband
thinks is right.
And the other is the cost and
benefits of having sex, which
is pleasant, and having babies,
which you might or
might not want to have at a
specific time of your life.
So both of these things are
traded off in some ways.
And the issue is whether people
do that effectively,
whether they do that
voluntarily, whether there is
some correction coming
from society or
something like that.
So social norms clearly
play a role.
So one example is this example
of Matlab, in Bangladesh,
where this program was
introduced, and a community
worker came and tried
to persuade woman.
One thing that has happened is
that, at the beginning of the
program, the introduction
was very, very slow.
The take-up of contraception
And then it started to explode,
the take-up started
to explode.
And then it comes down again.
So you get a little bit of an
s-shape in adoption of the
contraception.
And what kind of mechanism would
explain, what kind of
social mechanism explains this
kind of diffusion curve?
You must have seen that, either
in other classes or you
can think about it.
AUDIENCE: Viruses.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
This is how viruses spread.
This is also how iPads spread
or any new innovation.
And why does it spread
in this way?
Why does it have this shape?
AUDIENCE: If it's contagious,
initially, then a smaller
group of people haven't.
I guess that people that
interact with each other at
some point.
I mean it kind of depends
on something, I
don't exactly know.
I don't know the exact
mechanism.
PROFESSOR: Right.
But you get the drift.
It spreads mostly like viruses
or new products, which spread
mostly by infection.
At the beginning, no one is
infected, so the innovation or
the virus doesn't spread.
And then more and more
people get infected.
So they get chances to
infect more people.
So there is a sudden take off.
And then after a while,
everybody is infected.
So the infection has nowhere
to go anymore.
So that's why we find this kind
of mechanism, both for
viruses and for new things.
So the fact that in Matlab the
contraception had the same
spread, at first very slow and
then a sudden take off and
then flattening out again, when
the take-up was larger,
suggests there may have been a
contagion phenomenon going on.
So to look at it more directly,
there's a paper by
Kaivan Munshi, who looked at
what happened, whether people
do the same thing that
their neighbors do.
And so the first thing you can
do is to say, well, if there
are 20 women in my neighborhood
and 19 have
adopted the contraception, am I
more likely to adopt then if
there is 0 who have adopted?
And when you do that, you find
that indeed people, who had
more people who adopted
around them, were also
more likely to adopt.
So is that necessarily a sign
that they're learning from
each other?
What else could be going on?
AUDIENCE: It could just
be a copycat effect.
So it's not necessarily that
you're learning, but you're
just doing as you see
someone else do.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So the learning could
in a broad sense.
First, it doesn't have to
be learning something.
It could just be pure imitation,
where you're trying
to figure out what's the
fashionable thing to do.
So there is no learning
going on.
That's right.
So this is going to be difficult
to separate, but
even beyond that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I guess if more people
around you are doing
it, there is greater
demand in the area.
[INAUDIBLE]
supplies, but it's just
inaccessible.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there might be this effect,
which is it might be that, in
response to the first demand
from the people, there is an
excess in supply.
Or it could even be that it
turns out that the community
health worker is better in
that particular village.
And so, because she's better
and more energetic, she got
your neighbors to adopt and,
also, yourself to adopt.
And the fact that you adopt when
you neighbor adopts is
not a sign that there is a
causal effect of neighbor's
adoption on your, which could
be coming from copycat or
coming from learning, but just
that there is one common
factor that leads them to adopt
and leads you to adopt.
So what he does is that he does
something very ingenious.
He exploits the fact that most
of these villages have Hindus
and Muslims.
And there is only one community
health worker for
both communities.
But Hindus don't speak
to Muslims--
certainly not about
contraception.
And Muslims don't
speak to Hindus.
So now he's looking at, if it
was the certain hypothesis
that the reason why our actions
are correlated is
because of the community
health worker.
Should I see that, if I'm a
Muslim woman, there is also a
correlation between my adoption
and that of the Hindu
woman if it's due to the
community health worker.
AUDIENCE: Can you restate
the question?
PROFESSOR: So if it is due to
the community health worker,
should I see a relationship
between the adoption of the
Muslim woman and the adoption
of Hindu woman?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
If it is due to the community
health worker, because she's
serving both communities, we
should see this correlation.
Sorry, one more came.
Thank you.
Good effort.
But if it is due to the social
learning, should we see a
relationship between the
adoption of the Hindu woman
and adoption of the
Muslim woman?
No.
So if it's due to the people
learning from each other or
even copying each other, they
can't copy the Muslims,
because they never will ask
them if they are Hindu and
vice versa.
So he does that.
And what he finds is that the
correlation is only within
community, which is an
indication that, probably,
people are trying to figure
out what's the social norm
around the social group or
are copying each other.
And it's just not a joint
effect of the
community health worker.
Another way in which you would
peak at the social norm is by
watching what's on TV.
And there is a very nice paper
on the telenovelas in Brazil.
So Brazil is a very Catholic
country and, until relatively
recently, was not a very free
society, until about
15, 20 years ago.
And it was certainly not
particularly encouraging
family planning.
But the telenovelas, which are
like soap operas, became very,
very popular.
And they became very popular,
in part, because they were
quite good.
And the reason why they
were quite good--
I'm told, because I'm yet to
watch one, my Portuguese being
not quite up to crack--
is that a lot of people who
would otherwise have been
artists in other fields could
not really do it very easily
in Brazil, so they all went
and did telenovelas.
And they were aired on one
channel, called Rede Globo,
which was not available
everywhere at the beginning,
which progressively spread.
So what this article did is
that they looked at the
diffusion of the Rede Globo all
over Brazil and compared
the number of children that a
women had before and after the
introduction of Rede Globo
in places where it got
introduced.
So exploiting, in that way, the
progressive introduction.
Of course, the cities got
it first and then
the more rural areas.
So places that got it first, in
general, had fewer children.
But if we compare before and
after you get it, in places
that get it and places that
don't, then we get a sense
about what is the effect
of Rede Globo.
And what they found is that
the women, who were of
reproductive age after Rede
Globo was introduced, had
fewer children in their lifetime
then the places that
were in reproductive age
before Rede Globo came.
And another thing that was kind
of cute, as a result of
that, is that many of the kids
that were born in this area
were born after the characters
of the telenovelas.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
these telenovelas, the main
characters have few children?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Exactly.
The reason why this happened is
that the telenovelas were
promoting, not necessarily for
the sake of it, but the main
characters in the telenovelas
were people, some of them with
0 children, if they had
children, with a small family.
So they were promoting a model
of like a modern woman who had
few children, which kind of
helped or contributed to
slowly shift the norm.
Yes, Brazil expertise.
AUDIENCE: So it was is like
the main channel.
Like if there is one that people
actually don't have to
pay, necessarily, for it, you
just get it for free, if you
just have a TV So part of the
access to that channel comes
with some areas that are growing
into big cities,
becoming a little bit
more industrialized.
So that could be another
thing, stuff like that.
People are getting access to
the TV channel, that means
that the country as a whole
is becoming more and more
industrialized.
And they are sort of adapting
how many kids they have to fit
the model a little bit better.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So the actual cause
could be different.
Maybe it's not just the fact
that they were watching TV,
but the fact that they
gained access to it
and what that implies.
PROFESSOR: So what you are
saying is that TV came on the
tail of other changes
in the same areas?
AUDIENCE: Right.
Some places becoming a
little bit more urban
and how that's changed.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's a very good point,
which is always with this
different and difference
kind of strategy.
The always are worried
about that.
At least we are not comparing
directly the city to the rural
areas, but we are comparing the
rural areas as they are
becoming industrial enough
or developed
enough to get the channel.
Because, presumably, the channel
decided to come when
there was enough people who
were rich enough to buy a
television.
And therefore, they may have
been looking, not only at the
level of development of the
place, but how it was moving.
And if that is the case, then
we could be picking part of
those trends.
So that is something where we
could never be completely
sure, because we haven't
randomized.
So those underlying trends,
we don't observe them.
And so it's quite possible
that you are right.
So these doubts remain.
What the author does is try to
look at whether there are
trends in fertility before, that
the fertility was already
a little bit declining before
the channel came in.
Which we would probably observe,
if the stories you're
talking about is the one, which
is, as I see that the
place is becoming more
industrialized, richer et
cetera, I'm putting the TV
there, as the president of
Rede Globo.
And they don't see that.
They see kind of shift in trend
around the introduction
of the television.
But you might be
entirely right.
That's also why I like the first
name thing, that the
kids were named after the
people in the series.
Because that is less likely
to becoming from
industrialization in general and
more likely to be coming
from the fact that
you've seen them.
But that's very well taken.
AUDIENCE: Did they
observe a lag?
Like the introduction of the
TV show and the shift in
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly.
So that's exactly what
they are exploiting.
They are trying to look at,
particularly, it doesn't
reduce the fertility of people
who were already past their
prime fertile age when
the TV came.
It reduces only the fertility
of women who were in their
late teens and then early 20s
when the TV came, and whose
views were shaped by this.
And this is exactly this timing
that helps, to some
extent, discriminate between
the idea that the TV caused
the reduction of the fertility
and your perfectly legitimate
point that, in fact, in part
it could also be that TV is
just a proxy for the social
progress happening.
So these are all indications
that something, which is
probably not particularly
surprising, is in something as
fundamental and deep
as how many
children you want to have.
The social norms around you--
these are very local, your
village, your community, your
family, your mother-in-law,
or society as a whole, as
reflected to you by TV--
matter.
But there are also just plain,
simple, cost-benefit
calculations about do I want a
kid at this time, do I want to
take the risk of a kid at this
time by having unprotected
sex, et cetera, et cetera.
And one thing that I want to
argue is that people are very
good at making those
calculations.
And in the sense the key group
to look at for a test case of
this are adolescent girls.
Because in these countries and
elsewhere, we kind of suspect
adolescent girls to be not
the best at making those
calculations, necessarily,
which is why we see some
teenage pregnancies.
And so if they can calculate,
then it would mean that,
presumably, people can
calculate them.
Another reason why it's very
interesting to look at
adolescents, in particular, in
Africa, is not only teenage
pregnancy, but teenage pregnancy
as a sign that
you've had unprotected sex,
which puts you at risk for a
STDs, sexually transmitted
diseases, in particular, HIV.
So adolescents have been called
the window of hope in
the fight against HIV, because
A, they are uninfected.
And once you're infected with
HIV, you're infected.
You can't disinfect the people,
so it's better to
catch them early.
Second--
and that goes back to the point
that you made earlier
about was there a lag--
people's sexual preferences,
their habits, et cetera, have
not yet been formed.
And maybe it's right time to
catch them to influence their
behavior early, and then they'll
keep those patterns
for the rest of their life.
So there is a lot of effort,
the world over, to develop
programs to try to teach kids
to have a safer sex life.
And UNICEF worked on a lot
of these programs.
But unfortunately, in a lot of
countries, there is some
pressure to have this program
being mainly concerned about
abstinence and faithfulness.
So the strategy that is employed
in eastern South
Africa is called ABCD.
So the A is for abstain, B for
be faithful, C is for use a
condom, and D is or you die.
So that kind of encapsulates the
HIV prevention strategy.
But in primary schools, and
primary school in Kenya goes
till grade eight, and people
start school late
and repeat a lot.
So really, kids are like
16, 17, they're
still in primary school.
So think of primary
and junior high.
There was a policy decision that
was made in Kenya, which
is still a pretty religious
country, that condoms could
not be discussed in school.
So the ABCD program is really
an ABD program,
abstain or be faithful.
And, in fact, it's a program,
which is all day long, to
scare kids away and to say, look
everybody's dangerous.
HIV is everywhere.
The most dangerous kid is the
kid you meet in a disco.
I'm not making any of this up.
I've read the little UNICEF
books, where you have this
little cartoon of a girl going
to a disco and meeting this
boy and having sex and
then getting HIV.
So this is the type of thing
that they are trying to put
into people's heads.
So basically, the message
becomes, abstain until you are
of age to get married and
then get married.
Now the big danger with
that is that kids
decide, well, fine.
I don't want to die.
But I don't want to abstain.
So let me get married.
And the reason why it's so
dangerous is that means that
kids could get married early.
For girls, it means they would
have children early.
And so we would have very early
pregnancies, which means
that they would interrupt their
schooling, which means
that they would be, typically,
quite a bit younger than their
husbands, which changes their
status in the family, as we
are going to see in a
minute, et cetera.
So we decided to try and test
the impact of the ABCD program
against doing nothing and
against another strategy,
which is to basically make it
a little bit easier for kids
to stay in school.
How do you make it
a bit easier for
kids to stay in school?
You just pay the cost of staying
in school, which now
is just like the uniform.
So we ran an experiment with
Pascaline Dupas and Michael
Kremer, a pretty big experiment,
376 schools, which
were assigned to one
of four groups.
One was a control group.
One was a uniform group.
And the other thing we did is
we wanted to test the ABCD
strategy, so we accelerated
the training of teachers.
Because, in principle, every
school is supposed to
experience the ABCD strategy,
but, in practice, the teachers
are very shy about talking
about HIV.
They don't want to be branded
as an HIV teacher.
People are still pretty prudish
about the whole thing.
So teachers won't do anything
about HIV AIDS prevention
until they get training
to do it.
So the government has
a team of trainers.
And they went, and they
trained the people.
And that way the teacher
started to teach.
So we had four groups.
One, the teachers got trained.
One, the kids got
a free uniform.
And in one group,
they got both.
And these are some
of our girls.
And then we followed the
kids, all the way,
from 2002 to 2011.
So what I'm going to show
you is really the
results that are coming.
The results are as
of yesterday.
So you get like prime news.
Not yesterday, because I had
the slides on two days ago,
but like less than a week ago.
And what do we find?
So this are simple means.
And I tell you what is
significant in the means and
what's not.
This is your probability to
complete primary school in the
four groups.
So what is not surprising
in this graph?
Can you read?
You have the control group,
uniform, teacher training, and
then both is the uniform
and teacher training.
So what is not particularly
surprising in this graph?
AUDIENCE: They all exceed
the control group.
PROFESSOR: That they all exceed
And, in particular?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Both exceed just
teacher training.
And?
AUDIENCE: That both
is-- oh, sorry.
I was going to say what's
surprising.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, what is
surprising is fine, too.
AUDIENCE: It's the fact that
both is less than uniforms.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So what is not surprising is
uniform is much more than
everybody else.
In fact, control and teacher
training are
pretty much the same.
I mean, they are not
statistically different.
Uniform is much more.
I mean, you have to take care
of the scales, here.
These are not huge effects.
But getting a uniform, which
costs like a few dollars,
really nothing, increased
completion rates of primary
school by about 6%.
What is surprising is that both
is less than uniform.
You would think that it would
at least be just the same,
because at least they
have a uniform.
So why is both less
than uniform?
Not to answer the question, we
are going to continue and see
what else we're seeing in this
data and then come back to try
and figure out what's
happening.
That's a second thing which is
happening is whether or not
you are ever pregnant
by age 17.
It's like, if you're ever
pregnant or pregnant by age
17, it will give you
the same result.
So what is not surprising
here?
We can just describe
the results.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The surprising part
is that teacher training is
the highest.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the quite
surprising part is that
teacher training
is the highest.
So remember, this is an
abstinence program.
The abstinence program is
leading to a slight increase
in the number of pregnancies.
That is not the sign of
a successful program.
Which is the program that seems
to be doing the best?
AUDIENCE: Uniforms.
PROFESSOR: The uniform
program is great.
But what do we have, again,
that is surprising, here?
That both is above.
So not only the teacher training
does nothing, but it
undoes some positive effect of
the uniform program, both in
terms of school attendance and
in terms of teenage pregnancy.
So now let's look at
the STD infection.
So we tested for HIV.
And we tested for HSV2.
HSV2 is a form of herpes.
It's less bad than HIV.
It's not going to kill you.
But it has the same
characteristic, which is once
you have a biomarker for it in
your body, it never goes away.
You have the antibody for it, so
we know that you've had it
at some point in your life.
It's also good to diagnose
it, because
it needs to be treated.
It's also bad to have HSV2,
because, as other sexually
transmitted diseases, it greatly
increases the chance
that you get HIV.
The transmission rate of HIV,
if you have sex with an
infected partner, is higher
if you have another STD.
Because there are lesions
in your body that the
virus uses to get in.
So what do we find with HSV2?
So the reason we don't use HIV
is that one of the great news
of this project is
no one has HIV.
We have about 1% of
HIV infection.
So that's very, very low,
across all groups.
So that's good.
But there is much
more of HSV2.
It's about 9% in the
control group.
And here, what do we see,
with this graph?
So that is the result that
is brand, brand new.
The other results,
we already had.
That's the reason that this
is completely new.
AUDIENCE: If they had a uniform,
it makes you more
likely to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Somewhat
more likely, yes.
So you can call it the same,
that both uniform and teacher
training don't help.
Those are all pretty similar
in terms of standard error.
But it doesn't help.
So having a uniform makes you
stay in school longer.
It makes you less likely
to a teenage pregnancy.
But you're not less
likely to have
sexually transmitted diseases.
Teacher training, again, is
not doing anything good.
And then what now makes a
difference is the both
program, where, if you have
the two together, you're
significantly less likely to
be infected with HSV2.
So what do you think
is happening?
Any kind of story you can try?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but when
we wrote the book,
I didn't know this.
So you will have to
make one more.
We can start with that, then
you can retell the
story of the book.
And then you can say why that
explains that as well.
AUDIENCE: So my understanding
was that the uniforms kept the
students in school.
And as a result, they had less
time to do other things, like
have sex, which could
potentially give them diseases.
So it makes sense to me why both
would be more effective
in reducing how many people were
HSV2 positive, because
you would be more likely to be
in school and then you'd be
getting the training from the
teacher in respect what they
should not be doing in
order to avoid that.
PROFESSOR: So that
is possible.
So Ben's idea is that, oh, you
spend more time school.
And therefore, you have more
time to learn what the teacher
is telling you.
And therefore, that should
be the most effective.
But if that was the story, we
should see all of them going
down a little, and both going
down the most, right?
So there is something else.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because it has to
do with getting married.
So it still kind of goes along
with school, where I think the
people with the uniforms seem to
be able to stay in school.
And so they don't
get pregnant.
Because I assume the pregnancy
would come from
when they get married.
But they're probably, maybe
having safe sex.
Or, I guess, unsafe sex.
PROFESSOR: Unsafe sex, yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're still having
sex, so they're still getting
diseases, but they're not
getting pregnant and dropping
out of school.
Whereas with both, it may
be a category where
they're getting married.
And so now they only
have one partner.
So they're less likely
to get diseases
but not getting pregnant.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: For this particular
result, are you tracking the
students who actually dropped
out and got married?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
We tracked everyone.
That's why it took us forever
and something like $2 million.
But we attempted to track all of
the cohort that was in the
initial program.
Of course, a lot of
them have moved.
So if they went to Nairobi,
we went to
Nairobi to look for them.
If they went to Uganda,
we went to
Uganda to look for them.
So the first wave of them, we
managed to find about 60%.
And then in the remaining 40% of
them, we really put all of
the means to find them and
found about 80% of them.
And so the effective tracking
rate was about 85%.
And this has accounted
for that.
So we have all the married
people, the ones that have
dropped out, the ones that
didn't drop out.
They're all here.
So anybody wants to build
on the story?
So the story that I think is
happening is something very
similar to what you
are [INAUDIBLE].
Basically, you can have
two kinds of sex.
You can have casual sex.
And you can have sex with
a regular partner.
And then you can choose whether
or not you want to use
a condom or you don't want
to use a condom.
So you can choose your
level of protection.
Let's say you don't
like it so much.
You should like it.
But let's say, they don't
like it so much.
And so there is some cost of
using more protection.
But the advantage of condoms is
that you're less likely to
get an STD, and you're less
likely to get pregnant.
And then what people look at
is the cost and benefits of
pregnancy, of a pregnancy
now, as a teenager.
And the cost of an STD.
There is no benefit
of getting an STD.
And the probability that they
might get pregnant and the
probability that they
might get an STD.
And the cost and benefit of
pregnancy is the value of
having the child.
You might like to have a child
more if you have partner to
have a child with then if you
have to raise them alone.
So the value of a child in
marriage might be higher than
the value of a child with
a casual partner.
And then on the cost side is
foregone earnings, because if
you have child, you have
to take of the child.
They kick you out of
school anyway.
You can absolutely not go to
school when you're pregnant.
In fact, they just passed a law
saying that schools cannot
evict children that
are pregnant.
When this was happening, it was
the end of your schooling
if you had a child.
So the cost of the pregnancy is
that you're losing a chance
to further your education
if you wanted to.
So that's kind of the parameter
of what's happening.
Now we have the girls, and
they are thinking, well.
And of course, people like
to have sex, girls, too.
So they are like weighing,
like, what should I do?
How much sex should I have?
Should I use contraception?
And should I have a regular
partner that
might lead to a marriage?
Or should I have casual partners
that are not going to
lead to marriage?
And what the teacher training
program is telling them, if
you have casual sex, you're
very, very, very
likely to get an STD.
It does change their probability
that they might
get an STD.
But if you have sex within
marriage, you're safe.
You're fine.
In fact, it might do the two
things at the same time.
Maybe, girls have not realized
the difference between casual
sex and married sex.
But after the teacher training
program, they think married
sex is very safe.
And they think that casual
sex is very risky.
And the truth is that married
sex is not necessarily that
safe, because the candidate
for marriage, for a young
girl, is usually not a young
boy, who would be unable to
support a child.
It's usually an older man,
what they call a "sugar
daddy", who is able to provide
for the girl and then provide
for the child.
And the girls are convinced that
the "sugar daddies" are
faithful to themselves
and their wives.
But that might not
be entirely true.
And so the actual risk of
infection in married sex and
in casual sex might not
be that different.
But when the teacher training
program arrived, they feel,
oh, my god, I have to stop
having casual sex.
That's very dangerous.
Let me reduce, a little bit,
the sex I'm going to have.
But let me also move towards
married sex.
And by doing that, they're much
more likely to become
pregnant, because, within
marriage, they think it's fine
to have a kid.
And also, they think that,
within marriage, they don't
need to be protected as much.
So for these two reasons, the
pregnancy rate will tend to
increase if anything.
On the other hand, they also
have less sex, so that
balances out, which is why we
have a slight increase in the
number of pregnancies, in the
teacher training group,
instead of seeing a decrease.
Because we see a reduction
in sex, but that's
counterbalanced by a shift
towards this single
relationship.
And because the single
relationships are actually not
that safe, we also don't see
much in terms of reduction in
HSV2 infection.
Now in the uniform group,
suddenly the cost of staying
in school has become
much lower.
So staying in school becomes an
option, something you can
actually do.
So then you feel,
OK, I'm going to
try and stay in school.
But then I really shouldn't
get pregnant.
So you will move from married
sex to casual sex, use more
contraception, both because you
don't want to have a kid
and because you don't
want to be pregnant.
And that's going to reduce.
So you're going to
dropout less.
You're going to have
fewer kids.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Why does the teacher
training still have like a
large percentage of kids
with HSV2 positives?
PROFESSOR: Because the reality
is that married sex is not
that less dangerous,
in terms of HSV
infection, than casual sex.
AUDIENCE: But you're saying
there's not a statistical
difference between training
and both.
PROFESSOR: Oh, there is.
So teacher training
does nothing.
So, oops.
There is no difference
between teacher
training and control group.
That's because with teacher
training people switch towards
married sex.
And they think that's safe.
But that's not really.
Because they're having sex with
sugar daddies who are
maybe themselves infected.
So they do that, which is
why they have more kids.
But they think that it's safe.
But it's not safe, which
is why you get no.
And then I'm going to talk
about both in a moment.
So I've done teacher training.
I've done uniform
and now both.
Well, what is happening with
both is that, on the one hand,
you think casual sex
is very dangerous.
You want to avoid it.
On the other hand, you don't
want to get pregnant.
So married sex is not
great at all.
So you can't substitute.
The teacher training program
only pushes you towards one
kind of sex.
And therefore, so that
you don't have to
reduce your sex so much.
The uniform program pushes you
towards the other kind of sex.
And you don't also reduce
your sex so much.
But the both program, the can't
substitute, because
neither of them are so
great as an option.
So your only option is either
to reduce sex or to increase
protection or both, which is why
we get the biggest effect
on HSV2, but we don't get the
biggest effect on pregnancy.
Because we don't have this
switch towards casual sex,
which really doesn't have very
many pregnancies at all.
So that, I think, is what is
going on, which is we get
exactly these patterns
of results.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So you're saying that you don't
see this as all with
respect to pregnancy?
You don't necessarily
have a shift
towards casual sex there?
PROFESSOR: So this is what
we have for pregnancy.
For pregnancy, with the
both, they stay
like at the same level.
So you don't have
these big shift.
You really have very few
pregnancies in casual
relationships.
AUDIENCE: Does that tell us
anything about which one,
uniform or teacher training,
which is more [INAUDIBLE]
to be more responsible to?
PROFESSOR: So both of them, in
a sense, I think, teacher
training, they were responsive
to both of them.
But in the way that I just
described, in terms of their
thinking about it.
But in terms of the effect
you're trying to get, well, if
you're interested in schooling
or in teenage pregnancy,
asking people to stay in school
is the best thing.
If you're interested in
preventing HIV/AIDS and other
STDs, then you want to
add some training.
That doesn't make if for a very,
very easy policy lesson,
because that slightly depends
on you objective.
But for a very fundamental
reason, which is it
corresponds to the way people
decide and how they decide.
So it seems the biggest policy
answer to that is that you
shouldn't have programs that
are lying to people.
It just doesn't help.
So the way the program is
structured is to try and make
the girls as scared as possible
of casual sex.
But it would be a little bit
better to insist on helping
them to find a way to protect
themselves, both against
pregnancy and against HSV2.
So I think that's kind of the
lesson that comes out of this.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So along those lines,
how do these results
reconcile with the fact that the
teacher training doesn't
actually emphasize contraception
anymore, like
safe sex at all?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
These results are a direct
consequence of the fact that
the teacher training doesn't
influence contraception.
So they won't tell
you anything.
It's not an evaluation of
teacher training in general.
This is an evaluation of the way
it is done in Kenya and in
most of East Africa,
which is explicitly
ignoring the condoms.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
What I mean is like, in this
last finding, the argument
goes that, if you have both
teacher training and uniforms,
then people are more likely to
not be married but have safer
casual sex.
PROFESSOR: And fewer
sex in general.
AUDIENCE: And have fewer
sexual partners.
PROFESSOR: Less sex, also.
Both things will happen
on this one.
Because when you have just
teacher training, people have
the option to switch towards
the married sex.
When you just have the uniform,
people have the
option to switch toward
the casual sex.
But here, they don't have the
option to switch, because they
are scared of married
sex, because
they don't want children.
And they're scared of casual
sex, because they
don't want an STD.
And they think the probability
is high with casual sex.
So the only thing they can do,
because they can't substitute
between these two activities, is
either to have less sex or
to use more contraception.
And the teacher training,
itself, is not teaching them
about contraception.
But they all know, at some
level, that it's available,
and that it prevents
both pregnancy
and STDs, to a point.
So this doesn't tell us you
shouldn't train the teachers.
I think this tells us you
train the teachers with
information that is actually
useful, actionable, which
might not be such revolutionary
thinking.
But when you spend a lot of
time in education/health
circle in Kenya, you realize
it's actually a pretty big,
pretty controversial
statement.
So Pascaline Dupas, when she was
still a Ph.D. student, she
worked in this project, to do
something else, which we talk
about also a little bit
in the book, which is
the sugar daddy project.
And what the sugar daddy project
is, is to tell the
kids that it is not true that
sex with older people is safe.
In fact, older people are much
more likely to infected with
HIV than younger people.
So that's the information that
was given, plus a nice video
about a girl who managed to trap
someone who wants to be a
sugar daddy and something like
that, a very short, very quick
intervention.
A little film produced by
UNICEF and then these
statistics, which is your
chance to get an STD.
The infection rate of older men
is much higher than the
infection rate of younger men.
And sadly, the infection rate
of girls is also higher than
that of boys, for the reason
that girls are more likely to
have sex with older men, who
are likely to be infected.
So you are telling the girls,
you should really have sex
with the boys, because they are
safer than the men, not
quite in so many words,
but making
the information available.
And you're also telling the
boys that these innocent
looking girls actually
are probably more
risky than you think.
And this intervention was
actually quite effective at
reducing sex with older
partners, as indicated by the
number of pregnancies
with older dads.
It reduced the pregnancy with
older dads by 66%, 2/3.
So this is also another sign of
the fact that, if you tell
people the right thing, like
people will react to what it
is you tell them.
If you tell people the wrong
thing, they're also going to
react to it.
But they'll not react to it
in a way that is very.
You don't get that many more
HSV2, and you get many more
kids who are married with
older men and have
children too early.
So that's, maybe, the biggest
lesson from this finding is
you should tell people the truth
and assume that they
will be able to make the
right decisions.
You don't have to scare them
away into doing things.
So that's for that.
So I guess the key lesson
is fertility
decisions are like others.
We need to try and
understand them.
And this is one area where
policies have been based on
the assumption that
people are idiots.
And that's, I think, a very bad
assumption in general and
particularly, perhaps, in this
area, because it's a very
important decision that people
are much more likely to take,
with a lot of thinking and
with a lot of you.
So that brings us, pretty
naturally, into the next
topic, which is, if it's
a decision, inherently,
fertility decisions are
decisions that are made by a
man and a woman.
But if we think about it, a lot
of the other decisions we
talked about in this class are
also decisions that are being
made by a man and a woman.
And we completely ignored that
our discussions so far.
I've always talked about parents
decide how many,
whether to immunize their kids,
how much to feed them,
how many years of education they
should get, et cetera.
And in this, I've ignored the
dynamic of the family.
So now I want to spend
a bit of time--
not much, but the rest
of this lecture--
to talk about family
decisions.
So the question, here, we're
going to ask is, how do
families decide?
So when we mean family,
we mean who?
Like who decides?
The dad decides.
The mom decides.
The mother-in-law decides.
The kids, what do kids
have to play?
They are relevant to all sorts
of decisions that are taken
jointly by parents.
Until now, we've ignored it.
We've assumed that there was
something called, a family.
And yet the family, we
know, is a group.
So in what case would it be
legitimate to ignore the fact
that the family is a
group of people?
There are two cases where we
could say, well, we know it's
a group, but we can ignore it.
AUDIENCE: I would think all
families are the same?
PROFESSOR: All family members.
Like if we think that all family
members are the same,
they all have the same
preferences, so they all want
the same thing.
So anybody who has been part of
a family, does this sound
like a good approximation
to a family, the
way a family functions?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Not really.
I think it's not the case
that there are no
conflicts within families.
People have different
views about how
everything should be done.
And the second way in which we
could ignore the fact that
it's a collection of
individuals is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: If one person
made all the decisions.
So we had the mother or the
father is like the person who
makes all the decisions for
everyone, possibly taking into
account people's preferences,
but not giving them a voice in
how the decision
is being made.
Does that sound a plausible
model of the family?
AUDIENCE: At certain ages.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: At certain ages, of
course, like the infant is not
really in control, so someone
decides for them.
Norm?
AUDIENCE: Probably on the gender
breakdown, so the guys
will decide, or the male
in the family will
decide for the females.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it might be that in some
societies, there is really a
lot of control by the guys in
the family, as you say.
But that will depend.
Their society's say, you take
Pakistan or part of India,
which will be more patriarchal
than Africa, where the African
family is like--
it depends where, of course--
where there is more equality
between genders.
So no one, maybe, is like
in a position to
really, fully decide.
So maybe the assumption that
one person decides for
everyone is more plausible in
some cases, but we feel that
it's not going to
be always true.
And in a lot of cases, the
family is not one person.
The family is a collection
of people.
And they are trying
to fight it out.
So women and men have different
preferences.
For example, one area where
they have very different
preferences is how many children
they want to have.
So, for example, there was a
study in Zambia-- that I'm
going to show you in a moment--
showing that women
want to have much fewer
children than men.
So one reason, of course, would
be that it's Zambia and
the probability of dying in
childbirth is not 0, while if
you're the woman, you're more
likely to be the one who is
paying the cost of that.
So as Norm mentioned, the family
is patriarchal in many
developing countries, so maybe
men take lot of decisions.
But even there, you have,
usually, a little sphere, like
how to buy the food, et cetera,
where it's really the
woman who decides and
where bargaining
could be taking place.
So how do we test this?
How do we know?
How we can we try and see
whether the family is
patriarchal, is unitary, either
everybody agrees or
someone decides for everyone?
So if the family behaves like
one individual, we could
analyze the decision problem
of a family--
for example, how much food to
buy, whether to send the kids
to school, how many children
to how, et cetera--
like the problem of
one single person.
So the only thing that should
matter to a single person,
and, therefore, to the family
in this context, is the
family's overall income,
the prices of things--
how expensive it is to buy
whichever types of thing,
school fees, et cetera--
and information that you have,
to everyone in the family.
But if the family
is not unitary.
It's what we call this model,
where one person decides for
everyone or everybody agrees.
We call this the unitary model,
like there is unity in
the family.
So if the family is not unitary,
than other things are
going to start to matter.
So, for example, it's not only
the overall income that is
going to matter, but who
brings what share.
Because they can now, say, well,
if you don't do what I
want to do, then I'm just
going to take my
income and go away.
So now it's not the overall
income that's going to matter,
it's the share of the income.
So again, we could see men
taking much more decisions,
that's because they are bring
more of the income.
And we could see, maybe, that
when woman bring more income,
they would be able to
take more decisions.
The second thing that might
matter is private information.
So if you know that the family
is not unitary, and you find
something out, you might
keep it for you.
Because that gives you some
power to make some decisions.
So let's look at whether we
find evidence that private
information, that is information
that one member
has and not the other, makes a
difference in decisions and
whether it's who brings
the income to
family matters as well.
Let's look at these
two things.
So private information, let's
look at fertility.
So I was telling this data from
Zambia showing that women
want to have fewer
kids than men.
And in fact, they report hiding
contraceptives from
their husbands.
So in that case, you could
ask a question.
If I provide information to
women about contraceptives,
would it make a difference if
I provide it to the woman
alone or if I provide it
together to women and men?
So under the unitary model,
what would we expect?
AUDIENCE: Whoever the head of
the household is, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, whoever we give
it to, even if it's not
the head, we give it
to the woman, she's
going to tell the husband.
So it should make
no difference.
Or maybe it would even have a
bigger effect to give it to
the men, because they are more
likely to understand, they're
more likely to be involved,
et cetera.
So a lot of family planning
policies are now saying, we
have to involve the men.
Because after all, the men
have something to do with
contraception.
That's the idea.
Let's involve the men, and they
would be more likely to
be informed.
On the other hand, if it is the
case that women are more
likely to want fewer children,
then involving only the woman,
it gives her an option to hide
the contraception from her
husband and, therefore,
potentially,
to have fewer kids.
So it could really
cut both ways.
In the unitary model, you would
expect no difference or
maybe doing it to both together
would be better.
Or it would have a larger
effect, because the
information would be
more likely to be
diffused in the family.
Under the non-unitary model,
maybe the woman
would matter more.
So what do you think
is happening?
What's your bet?
AUDIENCE: The women use
it more when their
husbands don't know.
PROFESSOR: Right.
What they find is that women
use it much more when their
husband doesn't how.
So they did that?
Well, they ran an experiment
where they provided people a
voucher to skip the queue.
Because in Zambia, in principle,
you are allowed to
have contraception, et cetera.
But in practice, it
takes a long time.
The nurse calls you.
Once you've come, if you don't
have your clothes for an
examination.
So people don't really go
to the family planning.
So here, it's a voucher for
first class treatment, no need
to bring your clothes and
a good, nice setting.
So they did that.
I don't know if it was half.
But the separated the group in
two, one where they gave the
voucher to the wife, alone, and
one where they gave it to
wife and husband together.
And so the question is whether
women are more likely to take
care of their contraception,
whether they're more likely to
be able to control their
fertility in one
case than in the other.
So that's what the find for the
take-up of the voucher.
So the first two columns
are whether or not
you redeemed a voucher.
And the second two are whether
or not you get an injection of
contraception, which is a method
of contraception that
you can hide easily.
Because you got the injection.
No one knows that you
are not fertile for
the next three months.
And what you find is that people
are more likely to
redeem the voucher in the
individual treatment than in
the couple treatment .
And they are more likely to
receive the concealable method
in the individual treatment than
in a couple treatment.
So the effects are of the
order of, let's say, 55%
received a voucher in individual
versus 42%.
So these are not negligible
effects.
So it seems that it matters how
you provide information.
It matters also for the number
of kids that people have.
So this is the fraction of
births, in the months
following the treatment, among
women, who said, at baseline,
that they did not want
any more births.
So you can think of them as
unwanted pregnancies.
So six months later,
of course, you
should see no effect.
The couple treatment, which is
the red line, is a little
below, but that's not due to
the treatment, because it's
six months later.
And then at nine months,
the couple cross.
And the red line is above the
blue line for a few months,
which reflects about three
months of Depo-Provera use.
And then what happened is that
the effect on that, it
disappears subsequently.
And it goes up a lot for both.
And the reason is that there was
a policy change in Zambia.
All of the injectable were taken
away from the market.
So any effect of the treatment
goes away, because after your
first injection, you could
not get the second one.
So we should expect an effect
in the 9 to 14 month, after
the treatment, which is
exactly what we find.
So if we look at the number of
unwanted births that were
prevented--
I actually don't remember
exactly the number.
But it's a fair number of
unwanted births that were
prevented by going from
couple treatment to
the woman only treatment.
So that's the first indication
that the family is not
unitary, because who you are
giving information to changes
the outcome.
So people hide information.
The second information
is what economists
call bargaining power.
So even when the information
set is the same for both
partners, they might start
to bargain over a family
decision, who works, how hard,
how many children to have, how
much to feed the children,
how much to educate the
children, et cetera.
So the bargaining power is your
ability to weigh-in on
the family decision, if the
family decision are the
process of these discussions.
So what would affect a woman's
bargaining power, other than
the information she has?
So we already mentioned
an income.
What else could be there?
If you have good eyesight, you
can read it on the slide, but
you can also think
about it instead.
AUDIENCE: Maybe divorce
policy?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely right.
Divorce policy will affect
bargaining power.
And how does it work?
AUDIENCE: Depending on how
they allocate the family
resources after divorce,
I don't know there.
But I know in the past, in the
US, they would allocate it
mostly to the man.
And now, in a lot of
states, it's 50-50.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
If you live in a divorce regime,
where all of the
assets, and maybe the control
over the children, goes to the
man, then for a woman to
divorce is a disaster.
So when the take decisions, when
they bargain, they are
thinking, what is my
outside option?
And if I'm thinking my outside
option is absolutely horrible,
then I have to agree
to whatever
the husband is proposing.
So the divorce laws are going
to make a difference.
How much of the commons assets
can the woman get back, and
how much control of kids
could she have?
And in fact, it's been shown,
in the US, that when the
change that you talked about
was implemented, it was
implemented in different states
at different times.
So you can trace what happened
to women, in particular, to
decisions that are more in the
interest of the woman.
You can see that the decisions,
within the
household, improved in favor of
the woman when the divorce
law improved to give
women more rights.
So divorce law is one.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
like health?
So if the husband is in really
bad health, the woman probably
has a lot of power
in the family.
PROFESSOR: If the husband
has bad health, the
woman has more power.
Yes, that could be one.
Maybe because his outside
option is now very bad,
because A, he couldn't get
married to someone else,
because he is so sick.
B, he couldn't get by himself,
so he has to kind of be nice
so that she will continue
to take care of him.
AUDIENCE: So this slightly
related to a lot of them.
If you came from a wealthy
family or came from a family
with a status, the husband
couldn't get anything from the
family, but just so as
not to embarrass
himself in the society?
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
So the family you're coming from
will influence bargaining
power, because, maybe, not
wanting to embarrass himself.
Also, because it could be a
threat that my very strong
brothers are going to break
your kneecaps if you don't
behave with me.
So that creates like
an outside option.
Also, in case of divorce, again,
it gives you a chance
to come back to something,
whereas if you have no family,
then you have no options.
So that's very good,
your family,
where people came from.
What else could we have?
AUDIENCE: The relative level
of education [INAUDIBLE].
If she's just been to high
school, [INAUDIBLE]
make that economic decision.
She may not have the mental
leverage to say, what I'm
saying makes more sense.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So that's very good.
So the relative level of
education will matter, both
because, again, it creates
some different outside
options, because with a
high school dropout,
what would you do?
You're kind of dependent.
And the other point you're
making, which is not about
outside options, but even
your ability to bargain.
You might not feel confident.
When someone tells you that I
know better, you might feel
like, yeah, maybe
you know better.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
consider that a woman could
tell her husband, we won't have
intercourse if you don't
do this and that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Not only is it possible, but I
think that's a pretty frequent
bargaining technique.
So, in that case, if that's the
bargaining technique, then
you would think how attractive
each partner is and how long
they've been in a relationship
and things like that
are going to matter.
Because the level of the threat
is also whether or not
you think it's a problem or
you could figure something
else out if necessary.
What else would we have?
Well, one more is your ability
to earn an independent income.
So that's related to the point
you're making about education.
But it could also be just labor
market opportunities for
men and women.
So for example, if you live in
a society where women cannot
get jobs, because say there is
[INAUDIBLE], then what will
the woman do without husbands?
There would be a big problem.
Whereas if you live in a society
like here, where you
could get a job, if you needed
to, then that changes your
level of outside options, and,
therefore, changes the way the
negotiations would be made.
Another one is the
marriage market.
Is it possible for a woman to
get married or for a man to
get married after a divorce?
There are some places
where it's harder.
What is the gender ratio, how
many women there are for men?
If you are in, for example, an
immigrant community, where the
ratio of men to woman is very
skewed, because a lot of men
have come, new men have come,
then the woman can threaten to
get married to any of
those available
boys within the community.
That would increase their
bargaining power within the
family compared to a situation
which is more even.
People said that about China,
today, that one kind of
strange consequences of the fact
that the gender ratio are
completely skewed, due to
selective abortion and things
like, it means that women,
actually, are in short supply.
And therefore, it's getting
easier to marry them.
And they have a lot of
bargaining power within the
family, because there's no
substitute for them.
So all of these things
would matter.
So let's focus on one, for the
purpose of this, which is how
much money women and men bring
to the family, and, in
particular, how much money
they would have access to
should they leave
the marriage.
That's going to matter
for family decisions.
So policy makers are very
convinced it's the case.
So for example, all the cash
transfer programs that exist
in Latin America, to encourage
schooling and health--
like the PROGRESA program in
Mexico, that we discussed in
the case of education--
they tend to always give
the money to women.
On the ground that A, women will
make a bigger use of the
money, and B, that's going to
increase their bargaining
power and, therefore, increase
all decisions.
So there is very benign sexism
going on around in the policy
world that women are generally
better people, which I don't
necessarily disagree with.
But it should be looked
into a little bit.
So another one that is very
much inspired by this is
microcredit.
Microcredit claims,
the world-wide,
are almost all women.
Part of the reason is that
women are believed to be
better at repaying.
But part of the reason is also
that it was believed that it
was a way to introduce some
changes, within their
families, by giving power
to the family.
So does it matter who gets money
or doesn't get money?
I want to give one example to
prove my point that women are
better people than men.
Looking at one example where
money went into the household,
either with the men or with
women, which is the end of
Apartheid in South Africa.
They took a pension program,
which existed for white
people, which was, for white
people, a very small pension
program, in that it was not
a lot of money for them.
And also, almost no one was
eligible, because you couldn't
be eligible if you had
a private pension.
And most people have
private pensions.
So it was smallish program on
the side, a little bit like we
have here with minimum,
old-age security.
But at the end of Apartheid, the
new government had to make
a decision about, should we can
the program or should we
expand it to the black
South Africans?
Of course, they're not going to
keep two separate programs.
And they decided to expand it,
because it was believed,
rightly, that the older people,
who would be eligible
for this program, are precisely
the people who
suffered the most from
Apartheid, for
their entire lifetime.
So they expanded the program.
And every man above 65 and
every woman about 60 is
eligible for the program
unless they
have a private pension.
And very few of the black people
had a private pension.
So about 85 to 90% percent of
people who are eligible
actually get the program.
So the old-age pension program,
which is still there
today, it's a huge, huge deal.
It's a lot of money.
And it's very important
for the families.
And, of course, a lot of the
older people don't live alone.
They live with children or they
live with grandchildren.
And in particular, in South
Africa, it is quite frequent
that you have skip-generation
households, where you have a
grandparent, no parent,
and the kids.
This is for two reasons, one is
HIV/AIDS, which has killed
a lot of the middle
generation.
And the other is the way the
society was structured under
Apartheid, people couldn't bring
their family when they
went to work in the city.
So they went alone, and they
left the kids behind with the
grandparents.
So for this reason, about a
quarter of kids, aged 0 to 5,
live with a grandparent.
And that grandparent
can either be a man
or it can be a woman.
And the question we can ask is,
does it make a difference,
when this pension program comes
in, in 1993, if you
happen to live with no one or
with a grandparent, who
becomes eligible, or with a
grandfather or a grandmother?
So of course, one problem is
that the families who have a
grandfather are different from
the family who don't have a
grandfather.
So what we can look at is, let's
take a sample of kids
who live with a grandfather, but
let's compare the one who
lives with a grandfather who is,
let's say, 55, versus one
who is 65 or a grandfather who
is 50 to 64 versus 66.
So in both cases, there
is a grandfather.
But one is just short
of being eligible.
And one is just eligible.
So other characteristics of the
family should be more or
less constant.
It just happened that your
age is a good thing.
And of course, people couldn't
really predict that this
pension was coming, so the kid
lives with a grandfather and,
oh, he becomes just eligible
or is not yet eligible.
The same thing with the
grandmother but around 60.
So this is what this is doing.
This is looking at weight
for height.
So this is short trend
measure of nutrition.
As soon as you start
eating better, you
weight for height improves.
And in orange, we have
the boys, and, in
yellow, we have the girls.
And you can see that.
So what can you see?
Can you interpret this?
AUDIENCE: So this bar is
higher for eligible
grandmothers that took all
their grandsons in.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Heavier grandsons
and granddaughters.
And my guess is that, because
they're eligible earlier, they
have more to give earlier.
PROFESSOR: So this
is right after
eligibility in both cases.
So we don't have a longer time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's just to
show that grandmothers seem to
care more about their
grandchildren than
grandfathers do when they
become eligible.
And then you can also
see the bias.
So for grandmothers, it seems
like they treat girls better.
And grandfathers also
treat girls better.
PROFESSOR: So, basically, we
don't have much for the
grandfathers.
So the grandfather doesn't seem
to be using the money to
be feeding the kids.
And we have up a much larger
effect for the grandmothers,
particularly for the girls.
And some effects for the boys,
but only half the size.
AUDIENCE: Now why is it the case
that the grandsons are
worse off when their eligible
grandfathers [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So if we had the
confidence interval bar on
this graph, you would see that
this is not significant.
So this is kind of same-ish.
No eligible grandparents and
the bars for eligible
grandfather are around
the same magnitude.
What is really different
is the girls with the
grandmother.
And the boys to some extent, but
it's about half the size.
AUDIENCE: So could there be an
effect in that, when you have
an eligible grandfather, they're
older, so that they'll
have to spend more of
their pension on
like their own stuff?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So that could be that.
The grandfather is older.
And also, men live less
longer than women.
So actually, a 65-year-old man
is quite a bit older than a
60-year-old woman.
So that could be a reason.
So we can start looking
at this kind
of stuff, for example.
Also, they might want to save
more of their pension if it's
a grandfather, because he's
going to die very soon.
So it's more like a transitory
income shock than a permanent
income shock.
So you might want to
say, let's save it.
So we looked at saving,
too, to control.
And we couldn't find a
difference in savings.
The savings seem
to be the same.
But you're right, it could be
explained by that, that the
grandfathers need to be
spending the money on
themselves, where the
grandmother doesn't need to.
AUDIENCE: Also, could it
potentially be the case that
the grandmothers may be alone
in the household, with their
grandchildren, therefore they
would not have to spend
anything on other people.
Whereas, maybe in the culture,
it's more likely that a
grandfather has to take care,
also, of his wife, therefore
when he becomes eligible, there
is a greater fraction of
his income that also
goes to a wife.
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
That can be tested.
Because you can look at
all of the family size
configurations.
And you seem to find these
difference regardless of who
is who is who.
What is interesting, which helps
answering your question,
is the grandmother could be the
mother's mother or could
be the father's mother.
So you can look at, the pension
goes to the mother's
mother or to mother's father
or to father's mother or to
the father's father.
Which one do you
think matters?
Under your hypothesis, if it's
only due to the health issue,
what should we see?
That mother's mothers and
mother's fathers should be the
same and then the father would
be lower, because they need
more money.
And then, in practice,
what do we see?
These high bar is only their
mother's mother.
So it's only the pension
translating to higher health
of the kids if it's a maternal
grandmother of a girl.
So that seemed to have something
to do with these
gender lines.
And that doesn't mean that the
grandmother doesn't do other
things for the kids.
But in terms of how they decide
to feed the kids, it's
really the identity of the
kid that matters a lot.
So let me show you one last
thing, which is these results
seem to show, relatively
clearly, that the family is
not unitary.
So who brings in the
resources matters.
They actually do not show that
women are better people than
men, because we don't
know what men do.
Maybe they spend more on the
education of the children.
I only showed you
a very partial
window into the family.
So the only conclusion we can
take from this is that
families are not unitary.
So the next question we
might want to ask
is, are they efficient?
In that, they are bargaining
with each other, but are they
bargaining in a way that they
are first maximizing the size
of the pie and then deciding
to split the pie?
Or are they bargaining in a way
that the women would be
willing to reduce the pie as
long as she could get a higher
share of it?
You understand the difference?
So two people who would just
meet and who don't know each
other, will tend to interact
with each other like in the
prisoner's dilemma, that you
might have seen in game
theory, which is they will try
to grab as much of the pie as
they can, even if it makes
the pie lower.
But two people who know each
other very well, who are in it
for the longer run, might decide
that cooperating to
make the size of the pie the
biggest possible is the first
thing they should do and then
think about how to share it.
And this is actually an idea
we can test, because
households are engaged not only
in consumption but also
in production.
So if the direct analogy is to
first maximize the size of the
pie and then decide how you're
going divide it, are they
maximizing the production
that they can have.
And one way to look at that is
farming, because in a lot of
countries women and men grow
different plots of land.
So in Burkina Faso, the study,
by Chris Udry, looking at
households in which each member
is farming their own
little plot.
And an efficient household
should first use the inputs
the most efficiently possible
and then decide on the basis
of people's bargaining power
how to share the product.
Once we condition for the
quality of the plot and the
crop planted, we shouldn't see
that the women get fewer
fertilizer or less labor or
less input or less seeds.
And in fact, instead this paper
tested it and found that
women get significantly less
of every input, including
fertilizer.
And fertilizer has very
concave returns.
So there is really no point of
putting more fertilizer on a
field of the men, when you could
put a little bit on the
field of a woman, from the
point of view of family
production.
And that's not what you see.
You see all of the fertilizer
being spent on the men's field
and very little on the
women's fields.
Which suggests that the family
is not efficient, because they
could become richer by just
reallocating resources among
themselves.
So this suggests that the
family is not only not
unitary, but it is also
not fully efficient.
Which leads us to this question,
what role does the
family play?
What is the family
inefficient?
And what implications does have
to policy, which we'll
take up after you become all
refreshed from the vacation.